so you've all heard of anesthesia which
means no feeling synesthesia is a joined
feeling things coming together to
blending of the senses so it's
synesthesia looks like is somebody will
have some sensory experience coming in
and that will trigger an unusual sensory
experience for them so in this case a
taste in the mouth triggering sights and
colors and shapes now the thing about
synesthesia is its involuntary and
unconscious and automatic it's not
somebody making it up it's somebody
having a genuine perceptual experience
now that's all the animal research I'm
going to show because synesthesia is
fundamentally a human phenomenon and
what I'm showing here is the most common
form of it we're things like numbers and
letters and week days and months will
trigger an internal experience of color
for somebody so for example for this
person when she sees the letter J it
triggers an internal experience of green
for her she can see if I've written J in
black letter she can tell me it's black
ink it's not a hallucination but
nonetheless it triggers an internal
feeling of greenness now it used to be
thought this was very rare but we now
know that it's at least 3% of the
population has synesthesia so how many
people here have synesthesia with
letters or numbers or weekdays or months
okay quite a few quite a few people here
have it it's not as rare as we once
thought and it turns out there are many
forms of synesthesia so here's an
example of of auditory stimulation
hearing something triggering a visual
with colors so for this woman this is
what she sees when her furnace kicks on
it goes whoosh that's what she sees
visually um many people have musical
colors so things like notes of the scale
will trigger a color experience so for
somebody like
whenever you know whenever a key is
played on the piano or on some other
instrument they have this experience of
color this often helps them to tune
their instrument for other people it's
the tambour of different instruments has
different colors so for somebody a
clarinet might be golden and a piano is
always green something like that there
are many many forms of synesthesia and
the ones I'm interested in today are the
ones that trigger an experience of color
this is very common for this sort of
thing to happen now there's this
question about is it disadvantageous and
the answer is no you'll notice I have
not talked about it as a disease or a
disorder because it's not that it's an
alternative perceptual reality and in
fact it's advantageous because people
who have synesthesia tend to have a
better memory so for example these
contests where people memorize Pi 3.1415
are the ones who have synesthesia
because for them they can have something
else to associate the numbers with and
in fact there are some very famous
people called nehmen ists who have UNTAC
scible memories you can give them random
words and numbers and so on and they can
memorize all this stuff well the guy who
holds the world championship for the
digits of pi 30,000 digits has fivefold
synesthesia so for him not only does
each digit of pi have a color but it has
a texture a gender a shape and a
personality and so for him there's this
whole story landscape that's going on
and he's able to memorize pi out to very
large numbers